foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored in
New York City Spotlight of the media is
the BBC crisis intensifies Hugh Edwards
middle of broken the law as things stand
but he faces mounting claims not least
from the BBC itself that he may have
abused his powerful position to the
public have a right to know about his
private conduct we'll debate that also
tonight one of the biggest stars in
American politics as you've never seen
him before Governor Chris Christie says
he can beat Donald Trump including with
his fists
Boris Johnson says he can't turn over
his text messages to the UK's covered
inquiry because he's forgotten his
password as he tried the following
b-u-l-l-s-h-i-t that might just work
[Music]
live from New York this is his Morgan
uncensored
good evening from New York and welcome
to Piers Morgan uncensored there are two
things at the heart of the Hue em with
Scandal that we shouldn't forget one is
the well-being of a married father of
five who's clearly in a desperate
personal State now he's in hospital with
what his wife has described as serious
mental health problems of course we
should be concerned about him and his
welfare and the second are the mounting
claims of a potential serious abuse of
power by Hugh Edward was an influential
television star paid handsomely by the
BBC license fee whose alleged victims
matter too both these things can be
right at the same time but if you
believe Hugh Edward's private life is no
business of the press you cannot with a
straight face use it as an opportunity
to eviscerate the Press but the same
people occupying what they believe is
the high moral ground are the ones
turning the Scandal into a political
football Twitter's Ablaze with
moralizing takedowns of the media
well-known presenters are weighing in
two his former BBC presenter John sopel
I think there are a number of people
in the Tabloid press and dare I say it
in BBC News who need to give themselves
a good hard look in the mirror over the
coverage over the alacrity with which
they have gone into someone's private
private life and it hasn't been clear
what the issue is
now I understand emotions are running
High particularly for people who may
have worked at the BBC for a long time
with Hugh Edwards but let's get some
facts straight on Saturday the sun
reported claims by concerned parents
that an unnamed BBC presenter they
didn't name him had paid 35 000 pounds
to a vulnerable young person with a
history of drug use for sexual
photographs 20 years ago any newspaper
would have smashed the story probably
with the pictures gorging on every
taudry detail but the sun didn't do that
nor did they reveal the gender of the
alleged victim they didn't reveal the
name of the presenter they didn't say
that a crime had been broken they simply
reported what were serious claims about
a major BBC star which the BBC itself
had ignored for seven weeks after the
parents had gone to them first and they
did it in my opinion as a former tabloid
editor myself with extreme care and
caution the son has they say a dossier
further claims which decided not to
report and will be handing to the BBC
but still there's this narrative too
it does feed into a concerted political
campaign in this country against the BBC
and it's encouraged by the Murdoch
newspapers by the telegraph group and
the male group they want to see
effectively or certainly rufa Murdoch
does because he's talked about it wants
to see the end of the BBC they want to
see it destroyed
well hang on a second this is about a
newspaper plot to bring down the BBC how
do you explain what's happened since the
story broke the story has led every
newspaper and every TV and radio news
builders in Britain all week it's been
big news over here in the United States
they've revealed more details here
actually than the British public have
been told further claims have been
reported not least by the BBC itself
which has been investigating Hugh
Weber's it has been reported today
before the sun published what they
published last Saturday
BBC News reported claims on Tuesday that
a person in their 20s was contacted by
the presenter on a dating app and then
set menacing text messages when he
refused to meet the son then reported
claims from two more people alleging
Edwards may have broken lockdown rules
to see a 23 year old and sent direct
messages to a teenager on Instagram well
last night the BBC News night reported
that Edward sent suggestive and
inappropriate messages to Junior
colleagues and today we've learned that
BBC journalists as I say have begun work
on an exposure about Hugh web is
reportedly before the Sun newspaper was
ever involved so it's very convenient to
Brand This a tabloid conspiracy but that
is clearly demonstrably untrue at the
heart of this is a very sad story about
an alleged abuse of power by an
influential public figure it's grubby
it's shocking and for those who know
Hugh Edwards and I'm one of them it's
painful you don't want to think this
about somebody also important to say
he's not yet responded to all these
allegations but nor is he denied any of
them the public I would say have a right
to know and blaming the Sun newspaper
for reporting this originally when it's
the BBC which has been driving most of
the revelations in the last few days I
think is extremely disingenuous well
joining me now is former conservative MP
Louise mench talk to V presenter Tricia
Goddard times radio host Adam Bolton I'm
political journalist Ava Santina all
right let me start with Ava Santina
because I've been reading some of your
tweets about this you clearly don't
think it's in the public interest why
because it's his private life I mean
it's quite clear now there hasn't been
any criminality the Met police have
ruled it out so I've got no interest in
knowing who he's been dming or messaging
late at night I mean appears I could
frighten you with how many people come
into my DMs it really upset to my
partner I have to say but it's not
illegal and they are totally allowed to
do that and why should anyone know who's
in my inbox and why should I know who's
in his
Phillip Schofield was a scandal that ran
for weeks and weeks and weeks the BBC uh
did huge amounts of coverage of this
including on the very news bulletins
here Webb was presented what really is
the difference there was no criminality
there that's been established what's the
difference we had allegations about
Philip Schofield being inappropriate in
the workplace by having what was a
consensual relationship with a younger
employee Hugh Edwards has now been
accused not by the Sun but by the BBC
itself of inappropriate contact with
Junior BBC employees what's the
difference
I think it's fair to say that the BBC
might have gone overboard with their
coverage over the weekend and that is
probably because they are in the wake of
Jimmy Savile and they you know they're
damned if they do and damned if they
don't they have to report it properly
and thoroughly and that's what they
attempted to do the difference would be
I mean not to get into it too hard you
know too thoroughly but probably that
it's within the workplace and you know
influence and power structures in a
workplace are very different to
messaging people on social media sites
they just are
okay Adam Bolton um I've been struck by
the Venom against the sun here but I saw
you on Newsnight last night putting up a
pretty good defense of the the
journalism here I share your view I
don't see there's been any journalistic
malpractice by the sun in fact if
anything they showed remarkable
restraint oh yeah and we do have to
remember that there are laws that in
this country uh since 2018 and actually
the BBC uh broadcasting live pictures of
Cliff Richard's home being searched by
police on what turned out to be a
completely untrue suspicions uh we've
been told that there is an assumption of
the right of privacy in individuals
involved in criminal cases but I think
where uh Ava is wrong is simply that the
bar in this has never been criminal
Behavior the Sun never actually in its
initial story never said it was about
criminal behavior let's put it be quite
clear about it it's icky behavior and it
is behavior which appears to be related
to to an older richer powerful man
imposing themselves and in some cases
threatening younger vulnerable people
because the original young person
involved is said to be a drug addict by
his parents so uh his or her parents I
should say and we don't even know that
detail and again that can't be revealed
so you know the point is if you had
behaved like this and it was proven it
hasn't yet been proven in Hugh's case I
suspect that you would be sent or if I
had done when I I was an anchor I would
suspect I've been psyched or most people
in most workplaces if they were behaving
like this and when you are in a position
as you is as you are as I are in holding
people to account of endlessly doing
stories not just about celebrities but
about politicians and others it is
frankly a bit rich and pompous for
people like John sapol or indeed John
Simpson both of whom happen to be
friends of mine to suddenly turn this
into an Institutional crisis it's not an
Institutional crisis and the final point
I'd make is that the director general of
BBC Tim Davey said from the beginning
that he accepts this is a story of
public interest that is why he has a
license or not interfered in the news
Operation actually looking into it and
we've now got the situation where the
sun and the times are and this and and
the BBC are working together well you
know John Simpson there's not much
signed to me of a conspiracy against the
BBC by Rupert Murdoch no I completely
agree I think it's ludicrous to say that
uh Trisha this is a complicated story
you've spent most of your life dealing
with the complexity of human life and
human frailties and so on on one level
of course I know Hugh Edwards a bit I
met him at a few functions I think he's
always been perfectly decent to me and
people have spoken very highly about him
but that doesn't mean that you can just
ignore these allegations if they all
turn out to be true because there's a
whole slew of them now many of them
being reported by the BBC themselves but
let's wind it all the way back when when
the sun
um reports that the family first went to
the BBC because that's where I think
things went wrong where is HR in all of
this where where is somebody not pulling
him aside and saying you've got to stop
this right now maybe he would have got
help and the young person in question
had got help because remember they only
went to the sun because they were
desperate for something to do let me ask
you this on that point and Adam I think
touched on this yeah if it's this was
any other presenter I mean it was Phil
let's just go back and Rewind Phillip
Schofield if it turned out that Philip
Schofield had paid 35 000 pounds to a
young man because we knew by then he'd
come out as gay yeah uh would he have
survived this morning I very much doubt
it I suspect ITV would have fired him
purely for that Revelation so it
wouldn't doesn't it wouldn't need to as
Adam says it wouldn't need to pass the
bar of criminality no to potentially be
a sackable offense and therefore a
scandal but the the reason it's become
such a massive Scandal is because the
BBC didn't act all of it I agree before
that because if they had that quietly
and if the family when they went to the
BBC if the BBC had made more effort into
sending them a bog standard email yeah
and trying one phone call but didn't get
through if they had done that and done
their job diligently and properly this
could have all been handled by the BBC
and they might well have ended up firing
you Edwards and that might have been how
the world found out about this exactly
but it they didn't do when they talk
about
um care and a duty of care I mean mean
I'm sorry a lot of HR departments to me
seem to be attack dogs employed by their
corporations it's not about really
caring about the people who come and say
look we're desperate because our child
is using drugs for money for this man
where's your duty of care then well I
think we'll stifle it quieten it down
also where is common sense here Louise
while this was going on May the 19th the
parents go to the BBC and tell them all
this exactly what they ended up telling
the Sun the Phillips Schofield Scandal
is Raging on the front page of every
paper the BBC are reporting on it
morning noon and night the idea that
someone then goes to the BBC and says by
the way we have these concerns about
your main news presenter about what's
happening to our our young child who was
then 20 but had been 17. the idea that
doesn't ring massive alarm Bells is to
me absolutely extraordinary you've
really got to feel for the parents
haven't you and they physically went
down to the BBC I don't people
understand this they went to the
building yeah probably thought that's
the only way that they could get noticed
and they physically asked for help and
perhaps they thought when they were
watching Hugh Edwards and others cover
Phillip Schofield on the news at that
time that people would therefore pay
attention to what they had to say and
help them they might have expected that
they could reasonably get a bit of help
and they got absolutely nothing it makes
me sick frankly to hear the presenting
chattering classes talk about all these
various different young people as though
they were nothing as though they didn't
matter so this is Hugh Edwards private
life and there's nobody else involved
whatsoever because my make you should be
left but also trying to frame it as Adam
was saying try to frame it as some kind
of tabloid scam fueled by Rupert
Murdoch's hatred of the BBC seems a
pretty big reach given it's the BBC it
turns out today we're already
investigating allegations about Hugh web
was newsnite Victoria Derbyshire
apparently was already doing it and had
been been approaching people she then
reported some of these last night new
allegations bear in mind the summit said
we won't be doing any more investigating
and she accidentally drop his name well
I think that was a genuine error but I
think so but what are things more
pertinent is that she was clearly
already investigating allegations that
had nothing to do with this so you put
it all together and I just don't see how
you you position all this as something
the sun has done heinously wrong I think
Victoria Newton the editor of the Sun
and her journalists are to be
congratulated and I think all these
Murdoch haters should choke on it quite
frankly I mean I hate to tell you guys
but the story was true it was absolutely
true and it wasn't just this one young
person there were all kinds of other
victims or accusers if you like insight
and outside of the workplace how many
people need to come forward before you
guys admit that the Murdoch press got it
right and the BBC did nothing I mean I
do I've got to say I mean Adam just to
come back to you for a moment I do uh
think it's incumbent now on Hugh Edward
when he's well enough and I don't for a
moment he's had been very open before
about suffering from depression he's
according to his wife you must be
yourself going through a hellish time
with their kids at the moment and your
heart goes out to them of course it does
um but when he is well enough to talk
about this as a senior newsman himself I
think it will be encumbered on him to
properly address all these allegations
well I suspect he probably will and and
I would just make one note that in that
very very brave and dignified statement
by his wife which is the only thing
we've heard from his side uh in all of
this Not only was there no explicit
denial of any of the allegations there
was not a complaint actually about the
experience which he's going through and
I think that's because uh Vicky and Hugh
have both experienced journalists they
know that this is how journalism Works
uh when when people are held to account
and again I'm not saying it's
necessarily true but I mean those those
two things do stand for themselves and
as far as the the BBC and and not
picking up on this I think they fell
asleep on it the BBC is a massive
institution I don't think there's
conspiracy I think frankly it went it
was fed in you know they get a lot of
complaints nine out of ten you can
pretty much ignore and they come to
nothing on this one unfortunately for
them as you say at a time when people
were talking uh about Phillip Schofield
and ITV it kind of fell through the
cracks and and Tim Davey almost really
isn't denying that and on top of that
two police forces were pretty dozy as
well
back and looked at it so you know what
we are seeing is the fourth estate
collectively but obviously starting with
the sun actually you know doing their
job as the backstop in society well
that's the point is that the family went
to the sun in the end because they got
no help from either the BBC or the
police about this that's why they went
to the sun in the first place Ava has
anything you've heard in this debate
moved the needle for you and how you
view this story well I
correct to say that in the initial story
it didn't apply criminality but over the
weekend there were many articles online
that appeared and they used the word
child and a lot of the public now
believe that he was fraternizing with a
child and there's no evidence for that
that's a totally separate allegation and
totally different to what actually I
think so hang on hang on just to be
clear uh I don't think it's been denied
that this person was 17. but it's not
illegalism
there's no evidence but technically
technically to me is for example Ava for
example if any of these images had been
passed when this person was 17. it would
be indeed it would be that would be
illegal so we don't actually know the
full story here yet I thought it was
over 60. no it's it's 16 it's the age of
consent but it in terms of the passing
of sexually explicit images you have to
be 18. that's why people drew Drew an
inference on the fact that their contact
appears to have started when this person
was 17 what we don't know is what
happened in that first year when any
exchange of explicit material would
constitute a criminal act so that's
where they can Fusion and the
speculation may have may have Arisen but
look it's a it's a complicated story you
would you know as I said at the start of
this he's in hospital he's suffering a a
mental health episode his wife says and
your heart goes out to him on a human
level and to his family of course it
does but also you cannot ignore in the
way that some of those BBC journalists
or ex people say journalists seem to be
wanting to do the Welter of allegations
now which are there most of which have
now come from the BBC and they have to
be investigated as it would I saw for
example uh Noel Clark who was the guy
who got canceled for a load of a load of
allegations some women he didn't face
any criminal charges in the end and he
was tweeting did anyone care about my
mental health well they didn't I
remember there was absolutely total
unforgiving uh Slaughter for him
cancellation of his entire career and
you could argue well why is it one rule
for him and another because you happen
to be that face of BBC News
maybe more people out there who
shouldn't be throwing Stone I'm sure I'm
sure that may also be the case um but we
will see uh Ava thank you very much Adam
Bolton great to see you back on
uncensored thank you thank you to Trisha
thank you Louise appreciate it I'm
saying to the next Governor Chris
Christie is on a mission to take down
Donald Trump but whatever means
necessary including him he says
physically it's a remarkable Punchy
interview from New York City and it
comes next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
you're looking at live pictures here
from New York City that's the Empire
State Building Governor Chris Christie
is one of the biggest names in American
politics and he's on a mission to bring
down Donald Trump and win the Republican
nomination for the 2024 election it's
fair to say he's been on a journey
though when it comes to his old boss
he is a different political phenomenon
than anything we've ever seen in this
country he's a very good executive that
he'll get his arms around it the thing
that keeps moving this Administration
forward is the president and the
president's you know Charisma the
president's push I know Donald Trump
I've known him for 14 years and Donald
Trump is not a racist and there is no
one who is better prepared to provide
America with a strong leadership that it
needs both at home and around the world
than Donald Trump
well it's fair to say that Governor
Christie's changed his tune slightly
since then here's just a taste of what
he told me
look I think the rest of the world will
look at us and think why would you want
someone of that awful character and that
mediocre performance to be your
president
ah and he says he's prepared to get in
the Octagon ring and have a fight with
Trump and says quotes I'll bust his ass
it's just quite an interview
I spoke to Chris Christie a little
earlier he didn't hold back on
everything from Trump to his own family
life and to Prince Harry who he also had
a bizarre encounter with and is now very
scathing about it's a fascinating and
Punchy interview
good great to see you good to be back uh
how's it going how are you feeling about
running for president I feel great you
have been in it for five weeks
um I feel really good I feel like you
know what I'm saying to people is
starting to break through in terms of
what we're seeing in the polling you
know we're nine percent now in New
Hampshire only four points behind
Governor DeSantis and for five weeks
that's pretty good so we're feeling good
about the way it's going and I will tell
you that um I'm enjoying myself and I
think it comes through even what struck
me is a straight shooter you're a
pugilist by Nature someone punches you
you punching back yep Trump's like that
you know that yep um you were with him
for a long time I was what was the
Tipping Point for you to turn on Trump
election night 2020 appears because when
he stood up at 2 30 in the morning
behind the Seal of the president in the
East room of the White House and told
the American people that the election
had been stolen when he had no evidence
to prove that it was
to me that's undercutting our democracy
and people's belief in it and that is
beneath the office that the people
blessed him with and I think that you
know no one likes to lose I've won and
I've lost winning's better and it makes
you feel better but when you get in this
game you know that you can lose and you
got to be a man about it stand up and
take your loss like a man and put the
country first so that was the night and
I said it on ABC that night that I
couldn't support what he was doing and I
couldn't support him if he was going to
continue when you saw the Aftershock of
that on January the 6th with the rise of
the capital as a direct consequence of
his refusal to accept of course what do
you feel when you watch that
sick to my stomach
and and quite frankly astonished that
that could happen in our country I
expected that to see that in some other
country with a less developed democracy
some people have sort of tried to play
it down but I remember watching that and
thinking I think I've ever seen anything
like that in the United States I've
never seen anything like in the United
States where the actual embodiment the
physical embodiment the freedom and
democracy was under attack by Americans
whipped into a frenzy by a President Who
simply could not accept that he'd lost
an a fair democratic election I mean he
keeps talking about it being stolen but
as I keep saying to him where's the
evidence stolen there isn't any evidence
there isn't any and look
you could talk a lot of things about
about Donald Trump in terms of how he
lies
but let's just look at January 6th he
stood in the ellipse that day fired
those people up and said let's March to
the Capitol in our march with you
where the hell was he
he sent those people on a mission
to destroy the capital do you think he
meant for them to commit acts of
violence I don't think he cared
right which is as bad yeah I don't think
he cared I think what he wanted to do
was placed close to the edge of the
envelope as he could he wanted to
intimidate Mike Pence he wanted to
intimidate the Congress and try to buy
any delay he could to try to stay in
office you know he told me one time the
White House was the most luxurious Place
he'd ever lived in in his life and he
didn't want to leave well you know what
if I go to the White House I'm not going
to care how luxurious it is I'm going to
be honored that I'm in the same place
where John Adams and Thomas Jefferson
and Abraham Lincoln sat and we're going
to try to do big things for this country
he doesn't care about that he just wants
to do big things for himself you've been
a prosecutor when you see the evidence
obviously we've had the Stormy Daniels
case all right that may be relatively
small potatoes by comparison to some of
the others but it was an indictment
we've then had the the documents issue
at Mar-A-Lago which seems altogether
much more serious uh then we've got what
maybe more indictments coming on what
happened with the Georgia phone call and
there may be more to follow after that
as well around January the 6th he could
end up with four different different
sets of indictments on criminal charges
and yet still be able to run as
president and in fact still be able to
win as president and potentially if he
gets put into a prison cell which is
almost Unthinkable but it could
technically happen he could still be
president from his prison cell is that
right that that can happen in your
country no it's not right for it to
happen in our country but I'll tell you
our Founders never thought that anybody
would be such an egomaniac that when
charged with crimes they would still run
you know I remember everything that that
the media and a lot of people in America
said when I was a young man about
Richard Nixon
but when Richard Dixon was confronted
with the reality
that he was going to put the country
through an impeachment trial he put the
country first and he resigned even
though Nixon didn't think he should have
resigned but he did it for the good of
the country can anyone imagine Donald
Trump even doing that for the good of
the country and that's the problem I
love the people who say I know he's not
a great guy but I like his policies well
the question is if you like his policies
why would you ever hire him to get those
policies implemented they would say back
at you all right but you were with him
for a long time knowing exactly what
he's like I mean I've known Trump a long
time he hasn't really changed his
character he's gotten worse he's always
told Whoppers over the years right I
don't think he's been the king of
veracity for no decades right so to
suddenly wake up and go all right he's a
terrible liar I can't be with him
anymore how do you defend yourself
against the charge well you should have
stood up against him much earlier sure
because you know this this reminds me of
a story about one of your former Prime
Ministers prime minister Cameron I went
over to visit in 2015 and he was getting
ready to run free election and he's
telling me it's only 48 days the
election season in Great Britain he said
how the hell do you guys do this for as
long as you do it and to explain your
system to me and I said well David I
said the easiest way to describe it is
in America you don't necessarily get to
vote for you want to vote for you get
the vote for who's left
and in 2016 I ran against Donald Trump I
lost
who was left with Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton I did not want Hillary
Clinton to be president and I will tell
you as we sit here right now peers I
have no regrets of helping Donald Trump
get elected in 2016 because I think
Hillary Clinton would have been a
monumentally worst president nominee
this time round and beats you again to
be nominee would you vote for him yeah
I've answered this one before no you
wouldn't no what's the difference
between the last time undercutting of
the democracy
as I said when you show you don't have
respect even if you you would be more
prepared for Biden to win again in that
scenario I I hope that neither one of
them is the nominee but I couldn't vote
if they are the two nominees well then
the option is that by you would help
Biden no no I go on vacation so what
would it say about America if Trump wins
again
look I think the rest of the world will
look at us and think
why would you want someone of that awful
character and that mediocre performance
to be your president and I think the
rest of the world would question our
votes but let's face it peers there have
been a lot of times we look at other
countries too and we question the people
that they've elected I mean how many
prime ministers have you guys had in the
last election oh my God three years I
mean get me on my my country right so so
we all have questions about that but in
the end
America's role is a little bit different
and we are the leader of democracy
around the world we are the arsenal of
democracy We Are The Shining Light to
people who look for us to be able to
stand strong and defend Liberty in the
world and we need somebody different
than Donald Trump or Joe Biden to do
that it's very interesting you raised
that because I've been really struck by
the fact the Republican party in fact
all the candidates very split over this
issue of Ukraine and how involved
America should be some of the candidates
implacably opposed to any more
involvement if I want to remove any more
money and and military hardware and so
on many others completely full-on behind
Ukraine and supporting President Biden
and giving them what they need where do
you sit with this I sit fully behind
Ukraine we have to stand up against
those kind of authoritarian aggressors
and remember Vladimir Putin Donald Trump
says he's a terrific guy and a great
leader I don't know it doesn't look like
that to me I stand behind Ukraine for
that reason second it's a proxy war with
China
China is funding the Russians in this
war they are coordinating with Iran to
provide I'm watching this what happens
with regard to potentially invading
Taiwan that's right where I was going
Piers you know the Chinese are going to
look at this and say does America stand
up for its friends taiwan's a friend of
America if we're not going to stand up
for Ukraine guess what president XI
another guy who Donald Trump thinks is a
great guy and handsome too
um you know he he he thinks out of g g
will be in Taiwan
um faster than you could say Jimmy
Carter
um if we don't stand up in Ukraine and
so to me they have deserved our support
because of who they are and we in our
own national interests have to support
Ukraine to send a very clear message to
China Iran and North Korea
and says the next more from my encounter
with Governor Christian in today's
reaction to Trump's attempts to Fat
shame him and what is a family man he
thinks of Prince Harry and King
Charles's troubled relationship there's
an interesting answer stay with me for
more from that extraordinary interview
but the man who wants to be president
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
second part of my interview with
Governor Chris Christie used to work
with Donald Trump defended Donald Trump
now he's Trump's Nemesis and true to
form the former president has taken it
really well responding in kind by trying
to Fat shape him
and it was about our country and its
future
and I wondered
what our choice was going to be
we're going to be small
or are we going to be big
that was a meme which Donald Trump
gleefully put out on social media so how
far is Christie prepared to go in taking
the fight quite literally to Donald
Trump
let's find out if you and Trump got in
the ring he loves his UFC and stuff like
that right if you've got on the Octagon
you and him who'd win come on
guys 78 years old I'd kick his ass
I mean we know that Elon Musk Zuckerberg
apparently gonna get him yeah I can't
wait for that one do you want to be did
you see that picture of Zuckerberg yeah
looking pretty buff it does if I were
Elon I'd be a little bit worried I mean
would you be repetitive in the undercard
you're against Trump
look I'll fight Donald Trump anywhere he
wants in any Arena he wants um whether
it's on a debate stage or in the Octagon
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him Arnold Schwarzenegger I mean for
goodness sakes come on I mean look you
know what here's here's the bottom line
Pierce I I you know for the last 30
years I've struggled with my weight like
tens of millions of Americans struggle
with their weight and there are times
where I do well and there are times when
I don't do very well
um and it's a struggle and for him to be
such a child an infant and make those
kind of remarks especially I guess when
he's staying up in Bedminster New Jersey
there are no mirrors where he is because
all he needs to do is look at himself
and what he should do first work on
himself then when he gets himself
because you know he wears those ties you
know well as long as dies yeah eight
feet long because he told me this
because they slenderized him let me sell
it fail not working okay but here's the
thing at least I've never pretended to
be anything that I'm not
I I own my weaknesses I own my strengths
and I'm transparent about it people can
see it
um and when he says that stuff about me
to me coming from him it's a compliment
do you feel you were born to run
well it depends on what kind of running
you're talking about
on our last stop for president
look I think that that for somebody
there's a reason I'm asking you that
specific question well of course because
the other most famous person come out of
New Jersey yeah how many times have you
seen him in concert
currently 148.
when was the last time the last time
right yeah he is the last time was uh
uh in April at the Prudential Center in
Newark New Jersey have you ever met him
yes number of times because there wasn't
period when he was quite critical of you
well when I endorsed Trump he was not
quite yeah too happy with me yeah did
that serve other relationship it cooled
it it cooled it but things back on track
now you've been hammering Trump things
are getting better
things are getting better the New Jersey
Boys Are Back Back Together that's right
because now you're saying the right
stuff well I've seen stuff he agrees
with and I think it's right did you have
that conversation privately with him
did he try and persuade you no no no no
he more reacted to some of the stuff I
was doing
um and commented to me privately about
it what did he say I'm not going to tell
you well give me a hint that's between
me and the boss
laughs
Prince Harry in 2012 when Hurricane
Sandy I was a CNN when hurricane said he
swept through Manhattan I remember the
building CNN was in swaying it was scary
stuff the power going out the water it
was Mayhem uh Prince Harry famously
visited uh your state your guest at the
time and you did a walkabout with him we
did uh things have sort of moved on for
him since then what do you make of
what's going on with Megan and Harry and
their journey to Freedom I've never met
Megan so it's hard for me and I I try as
someone who is a public figure to not
judge too much based upon what I read or
see so I don't have really any opinions
on Megan
I found Harry when I met him in 2012 to
be a really kind-hearted young man
but also a pretty sad and Confused one
and I'll give you one example he he um
we were to exchange gifts
when he got off the helicopter in New
Jersey and I had a fleece like the
fleece I was wearing during Hurricane
Sandy I gave him a fleece that said
Prince Harry on it he didn't give me a
gift back and I thought all right well
he must have gotten the briefing wrong
or whatever we later went back to the
governor's beach house to have lunch
together after the walkabout and um
he said now look I have a gift for you
he said but I didn't want to give it in
front of all those people and I will
give it to you now but only if you
promise not to open it until I leave
and I said why and he said because they
make me give this and it makes me very
uncomfortable
so I said fine Harry and he goes into
his bag and is this wrapped gift and he
puts it on the table and I honored his
request and didn't open it when we
opened it afterwards it was a framed
picture framed autographed picture of
himself
I swear to you and and what did you do
with it I gave it to my daughter um who
thought he was really cute
so so she kept the picture and she still
has it it's interesting what's happened
to them because uh the Spotify executive
kind of summed up what many people think
and called them effing little grifters
yeah
um very unpopular in the UK now because
they've basically trashed the royal
family so yeah obviously what do you
think of that I think it's all you're a
big family man I am I think it's awful I
think if you have those kind of disputes
with your father with your brother other
members of your family that that's fine
families fight but they need to fight
inside the family right and and I think
when he decided to go public with all of
that and the only conclusion I can draw
are two one that it was somehow
cathartic for him and he's obviously a
troubled young man and who could wonder
about that because of his mother's
passing at such a young age but secondly
it had to be to make money
and and I think that that to trash your
family for cash I totally agree um I
think is is beneath someone who's been
given all the honors he's been given
over the course of his life and so but
the good thing is I'm hopeful that you
know his father now has what he's always
wanted
and I'm hoping that King Charles will be
um forgiving I think he's tried but I
think he's pretty much at the stage of
washing his hands of him now because the
the attacks well that's incredibly sad
if that's what it is I think he can't
trust him every time he turns up he just
takes all the material he Gunners back
and puts it in some other publication
and that's if that's what it is then
then you know as even as a father there
are moments where you just have to walk
away but I'll tell you as a father of
four that it would be really hard for me
to walk away from any of my children
yeah and if that's who the king is it's
a pretty sad place for him too not his
fault necessarily at all but a sad place
for him at a moment in his life when he
should be really pretty happy he's got
the woman he's always loved and he's got
the job he always wanted just go forward
a bit you knock out Trump you win the
presidency inauguration day what do you
say to the American people
that it's time for us once again to put
our country first it's time for us to
put aside some of our differences and
figure out areas where we can work
together and compromise and that the
kind of President I would hope to be
would be one that would be able to forge
those compromises and sacrifice my own
popularity
to be able to make action happen your
mother said to you before she died that
far more important to be respected than
to be loved because if you're respected
the love comes down the line I thought
it was really good advice it was great
would you say that advice into a
presidency it's it's the advice I take
into every day of my life it's not just
into my jobs it's into the way I deal
with my kids too
I want to be a someone who they respect
in addition to someone they love because
if they respect me then they're going to
come to me when they have problems
they're going to come to me for advice
they're going to come to me when they
just need to cry
and that's the kind of respect that if I
were to become president I'd want the
American people to know that every day
I'd be working as hard as I could to
make them feel that respect for me but
more importantly for them to feel proud
of their country and I think there are
moments now where Americans don't feel
proud of our country because of some of
the things we're failing to do and I
want us to do the big things the thing
that I always wanted when I was governor
I used to say to my folks all the time
don't tell me about what's how something
will affect my ratings today tell me if
it's something that really is
consequential I want to be a governor of
consequence and I believe I was
and that's the kind of presence I want
to be to do the big things to be a
president of the consequence Governor
great to see you again good to see you
pierce
where'd you go watch the full interview
with Chris Christie on the Piers Morgan
uncensored YouTube channel from right
now
I'm sense of next tonight Boris
Johnson's been unable to give the covert
inquiry WhatsApp messages from his own
phone because he can't remember his
passcode I've got a few suggestions for
him as to what that might be and I'll
share them with you after the break
[Music]
good evening I'm Peters Morgan
uncensored in New York City tonight on
Piers Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Petersburg Special Edition
from cancer tonight a special edition
appears more than uncensored Martina
navratulations remember me cry again do
you believe you can win this war so are
you gonna run again I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy yes I
feel betrayed they're trying to force
you out yes not only the coach but the
other two or three guys there around all
these protesting just don't get many of
them don't it's not slightly patronizing
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessments I'd be there for three weeks
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read
the book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
let's see where are they where's their
children
it's from that much cushier gel that
galane Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him you're shaking
is out as British prime minister the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
this is the Royal team question is did
he say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules to give them the
Visa or lied on the visa application
form and therefore got it
oh
what is a woman me
let it roll a woman is given to the man
in marriage Andrew You're simply wrong
I've been a terrible liar that's true I
mean would you be prepared to say that
I've been a terrible liar are you sorry
you said that
I think it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned which is your favorite
nickname that Trump's giving us Rhonda
sanctimonious or meatball Rock I've seen
you clown Tommy Fury so please go easy
on me bro you weren't asked to give
evidence to the grand jury I have
nothing to hide I'm the only one that
has been telling the truth if you had to
come up against a team that had a
Russian player would you shake that no
chance no chance it's life and death
This Is War Pass Morgan
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves to know what happened you don't
drink never taken drugs you're stinking
Rich should we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
coming up on the talk the BBC resumes
its investigation into Hugh Edwards as
it's reported the broadcaster's own
journalists are working on more
potential stories about the Scandal
Harry and Megan are nominated for a
Hollywood award for their tell-all TV
show and would Britain's roads be safer
if only women were behind the wheel
that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to peers organizers live
from Manhattan you can see the Sixth
Avenue uh buzzing with activity at this
time of day mid-afternoon over here in
New York I'm rejoined by my former
conservative MP Louise Minch and talk to
your presenter Tricia Goda quick
reaction to Chris Christie interesting
character very engaging charismatic and
going hardcore on Trump I thought that
was a hilarious interview and he's
actually met him outside just when
you're doing that interview he's a
really nice guy I think he's very
sincere and he sees straight through
Donald Trump in that kind of earthy New
Jersey way I think he'd be a very good
president yeah I mean he's an impressive
character isn't he he is he really is
and I love the way that he took the
whole fat thing and literally has run
with it you know if somebody's going to
call you a name own it take it and make
capital and are we to assume that the
narcissistic streak that we guessed
Prince Harry's developed may have
actually been there all along given he
gives people like Chris Christie a gift
of a signed picture of himself
[Laughter]
back in the day he actually didn't like
publicity imagine that what a change in
the science in the shine retiring days
before he he commercialized his private
life and the small moved to Boris
Johnson who's conveniently forgotten the
passcode to his iPhone which means he
can't hand over all the crucial messages
from the start of the pandemic to the
covert inquiry until they can guess the
passcode of the course but you only get
10 goes and then basically your phone
that's it you can never get into it
again Apple can't do we've had this with
the FBI do does anyone believe he can't
remember his passcode I do actually
because it was 2021.
is pushing forward the idea that Britain
should be in charge of policing AI how's
he going to look that they're Tech Guys
in Parliament can't sort that out in
five seconds I just don't believe a word
I think Boris Johnson knows exactly what
his passcode is and I suspect he doesn't
want people to see the truth about
what's in those messages at the start of
the pandemic and there's probably a very
good reason why he doesn't want us to
see it for time so I sincerely hope it
and also I don't think if you're prime
minister then I think you should give
your passwords as a matter of public
record
HQ why doesn't gchq our intelligence
agency have a copy of that password even
as a matter of National Security
intelligence because what happens if you
suddenly drop dead and they needed to
find information that was on his phone I
think it's ridiculous um
how many children he's got yeah does he
know the Boris Johnson no I don't think
he's got a clue about Joseph
um talking of uh strange things
Maybelline which is the company that
promotes amongst other things uh
lipstick it's a Cosmetics company
they've come under Fire for using two
men with beards to promote their new
lipstick here we are now look oh
cares every time I think the this sort
of farcical nonsense couldn't get more
ridiculous Trisha I mean you don't think
it's not aimed at you darling dad
younger people who couldn't give a stuff
I mean if these people would not woman
is gonna what woman is such a great big
balls it's funny smearing lips are gone
so I must go and buy that it's
commercial yeah young guys wear lipstick
what makeup oh yes come on you said Your
son's an actor he must wear makeup you
were in the makeup it was makeup to act
obviously we're not not to go out for
the night Louise no what's happening to
the world I think honestly I think some
of these um some of these companies are
just trolling women at this point I mean
well they're also trolling they're also
trolling their business models because
we saw them with Bud uh Budweiser with
Dylan Mulvaney that's right who likes to
specialize says look I'm trans since
last year but now specializes in mocking
women right so Budweiser's bottom line
takes a massive hit the same thing is
going to happen here women don't want to
see big Blowfish
just one second I mean I'm going to be
voting with with my wallet because
honestly how am I supposed to know what
that lipstick is going to look like on
me
I totally agree the whole thing is
utterly ridiculous what it is it's all
these companies have been infested with
wokies oh and they sit there oh there
you go how can we think of a really
great Campaign which was greater our
stock price
I know let's promote a great big ball
boat with a beard listen
is for years and years and years we
people have let me put it in early while
you bring up color we didn't know what
makeup would look out like on us we
still bought it I don't care here's my
prediction their share price will take
it I'll buy the list I love it women
will vote with their feet and they'll go
to a Cosmetic Company which actually
wants to celebrate women labeling not
brilliant
brilliant uh on that bombshell it's
great to see you both thank you both
very much indeed I've got to say you've
been heroic this week oh thank you so
much
you should get a medal for putting up
with me uh yes
yeah probably both of us should get
medals but you've been great this way
it's always good to catch up with you
it's been another fun week in New York
City next week I will be back in London
uh with more uncensored material on my
final advice to you from New York City
from the bowels of Manhattan is whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored that's
it see you next week good night
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign